cuando un jugador de ligas mayores lanza
una bola rápida esa bola definitivamente
tiene energía cinética eso lo sabemos
porque si nos atravesamos en el camino
de la pelota estaba hace el trabajo
sobre nosotros y nos va a doler así que
hay que tener cuidado pero esta es mi
pregunta el hecho de que la mayoría de
los lanzamientos a menos que lancemos
una bola lenta el hecho de que la
mayoría de los lanzamientos que se
envían hacia home tienen este giro
rotacional significa que esta bola tiene
una energía cinética extra pues si así
es y como nos damos cuenta de esto ese
es el objetivo de este vídeo cómo
podemos determinar cuál es la energía
cinética rotacional en un objeto bueno
si yo viera esto por primera vez mi
primera idea sería bueno yo ya sé cómo
luce la fórmula de la energía cinética
normal o regular y es de un medio por la
masa por la velocidad al cuadrado y si
yo digo que ahora quiero la energía
cinética rotacional que le vamos a
llamar k
bueno yo sé que para objetos que están
rotando el equivalente rotacional de la
masa es el momento de inercia por lo que
puedo decir bueno en lugar de la masa
voy a usar el momento de inercia ya que
la segunda ley de newton para la
rotación se que usa el momento de
inercia en lugar de la masa así que lo
reemplazo aquí y en lugar de la
velocidad al cuadrado ya que tengo algo
que está rotando voy a poner la
velocidad angular al cuadrado y resulta
que esto funciona siempre podemos no
deducir pero sin adivinar educadamente
la fórmula para la energía cinética
rotacional la fórmula rotacional análoga
de alguna fórmula lineal simplemente
sustituyendo los análogos rotacionales
de cada una de las variables
reemplazando la masa con la masa
rotacional así obtengo el momento de
inercia si reemplazo la velocidad con la
velocidad rotacional obtengo la
velocidad angular y esta es la fórmula
correcta
en este vídeo vamos a deducir esta
fórmula aunque realmente no la estamos
reduciendo solo estamos mostrando que es
posible usarla como podríamos demostrar
que esta es la fórmula de la energía
cinética rotacional de un objeto que
esté rotando como esta pelota de béisbol
lo primero que tenemos que reconocer es
que esta energía cinética rotacional no
es un nuevo tipo de energía cinética
sigue siendo la vieja y regular energía
cinética para algo que está rotando y
con esto quiero decir que imaginen que
esta bola de béisbol está rotando
circularmente cada punto en esta pelota
de béisbol está rotando y moviéndose con
cierta rapidez es decir imagínense este
pedacito de cuero va a tener cierta
rapidez hacia adelante ya este pedacito
de cuero le voy a llamar m1 es un
pedacito de masa aquí y a su rapidez le
voy a llamar b1 de forma similar este
punto de cuero aquí le voy a llamar m2 y
se va a estar moviendo hacia abajo
están rotando en un círculo su rapidez
será de 2 y los puntos que estén cerca
del eje se van a estar moviendo con una
menor rapidez este punto de aquí que le
llamamos m3 que se mueve hacia abajo con
una rapidez de tres ésta no será tan
grande como b2 o como b1 esto no se nota
muy bien voy a usar un verde más oscuro
este es de 3 y más cercano al eje el eje
está aquí en este punto de acá mientras
más cercano esté al eje su rapidez será
menor comparado con los puntos que se
encuentran más lejanos a este eje y
pueden darse cuenta de que esto es un
poco complicado todos los puntos de esta
pelota se van a estar moviendo con
diferentes rapidez así que los puntos
que estén acá muy cerca del eje apenas
se van a mover vamos a llamarle a este m
4 y se moverá con una rapidez de 4 y a
lo que nos referimos con la energía
cinética rotacional es toda la energía
cinética regular que tienen estas
pequeñas masas
alrededor del centro de masa en otras
palabras a qué nos referimos con cada
rotacional pues simplemente vamos a
sumar todas estas energías cinéticas
tenemos un medio m 1 por b 1 al cuadrado
más la energía cinética de esta masa 2
es un medio por m2 por b 2 al cuadrado
ya que tiene este punto cierta energía
cinética y no se preocupen de que tenga
una dirección hacia abajo como estamos
elevando las velocidades o la rapidez al
cuadrado el signo no importa la energía
cinética no es un vector por lo que no
importa que cierta velocidad apunta a
cierta dirección y otra velocidad apunte
a otra dirección ya que sólo estamos
interesados en la rapidez y de forma
similar sumamos un medio por m3 por b 3
al cuadrado y ustedes me pueden decir
esto es imposible cómo es que voy a
sumar todos los puntos que se encuentran
en esta bola hay una cantidad infinita
de puntos aquí cómo voy a poder sumarlos
todos
bueno pues algo mágico está por suceder
y esto
una de las deducciones que más me gustan
es pequeño y elegante vea lo que sucede
cada rotacional simplemente es la suma
de todos estos puntos lo voy a escribir
como la suma de todos los un medio por m
por b al cuadrado de cada uno de los
puntos que se encuentran en esta bola de
béisbol imagínense descomponer esta
pelota en pedacitos muy pequeños no lo
hagan de verdad solo imagínense que lo
hacen visualizan pequeños pedazos de
esta bola de béisbol y qué tan rápido se
mueven y lo que quiero decir es que si
sumamos todo eso vamos a tener la
energía cinética rotacional total y luce
imposible de realizar
pero algo mágico va a suceder eso es lo
que podemos hacer aquí el problema es la
vez ya que todos estos puntos tienen una
rapidez diferente ve y podemos usar un
truco que nos gusta mucho usar en física
en lugar de escribir esto como ve la
vamos a reemplazar por recuerden que
para algo que
está rotando ve es igual a r por mega el
radio o qué tan lejos nos encontramos
del eje x la velocidad angular o la
rapidez angular esto nos va a dar la
velocidad regular y esta fórmula es muy
útil así que vamos a reemplazar ve con r
por omega y esto lo tenemos que elevar
al cuadrado también y quizá en este
punto me digan que está saliendo peor
esto para que lo estamos haciendo pues
fíjense aquí tengo la suma de un medio
por m por r al cuadrado por omega al
cuadrado y la razón por la que esto es
mejor es que ya que cada punto de la
bola va a tener una velocidad diferente
todos estos puntos van a tener la misma
rapidez angular omega y eso es lo bueno
de estas cantidades angulares son las
mismas para cada uno de los puntos en
esta bola de béisbol sin importar qué
tan lejos se encuentren del eje o qué
tan cerca estén y ahora ya puedo
realizar esta suma voy a escribir esta
suma pero sacando todo lo que es
constante esto lo escribo como 1
me dio por la suma de m por r al
cuadrado aquí termina esta suma y sacó a
la omega al cuadrado ya que es la misma
para cada terminó prácticamente factor
izando esto de todos estos puntos es
como tenemos aquí arriba cada uno de
éstos tiene un medio y podemos
imaginarnos factor izando s un medio y
escribir toda esta cantidad como un
medio x m 1 x b 1 al cuadrado más m2 por
b 2 al cuadrado etcétera y es lo que
estoy haciendo aquí para en un medio y
para la omega al cuadrado y esto es lo
bueno de reemplazar la b con r por omega
la omega va a ser la misma para todos y
quizás les preocupe que sigamos teniendo
esta m aquí ya que tenemos diferentes
emes en diferentes puntos y también
estamos atorados con todas estas r al
cuadrado ya que todos estos puntos de la
bola de béisbol tendrán eres diferentes
ya que son diferentes puntos alrededor
del eje y tendrán distancias diferentes
esto
no los podemos factorizar qué vamos a
hacer ahora pues si son listos seguros
se darán cuenta de que reconocen este
término este término de la suma no es
nada más que el momento de inercia total
de este objeto recuerden que el momento
de inercia de un objeto que ya vimos con
anterioridad
es simplemente m por r al cuadrado el
momento de inercia de una masa puntual
es m por el re al cuadrado y el momento
de inercia de muchas masas puntuales es
la suma de todas las m por r al cuadrado
y esto es justamente lo que tenemos aquí
esto es justamente el momento de inercia
de esta bola de béisbol o cualquiera que
sea el objeto que estamos analizando y
no tiene que tener una forma en
particular cuando sumamos todas las m
por r al cuadrado esto va a ser igual el
momento de inercia total así que lo que
encontramos es que nuestra carrot
acional es igual a un medio muy
replicado por esta cantidad que es i
mayúscula el momento de inercia
multiplicado por omega al cuadrado
es la fórmula que obtuvimos aquí arriba
cuando sólo estábamos adivinando que
podría ser pero en efecto funciona y
acabamos de ver porque si funciona ya
que siempre vamos a tener esta cantidad
aquí abajo un medio de iu por megal
cuadrado sin importar cual sea la forma
del objeto y qué es lo que nos da esta
cantidad pues es la energía cinética
rotacional total de todos los puntos en
esta masa alrededor del centro de masa
pero hay algo que no nos dice este
término de aquí no nos incluye la
energía cinética traslacional el hecho
de que esta pelota de béisbol esté
volando por el aire no está incorporado
en esta fórmula no tomamos en cuenta el
hecho de que esta bola de béisbol está
viajando por el aire es decir no estamos
tomando en cuenta que el propio centro
de masa de esta bola de béisbol se está
trasladando a través del aire pero eso
lo podemos hacer fácilmente con esta
fórmula de acá esta es la energía
cinética traslacional a veces en lugar
de escribir la energía cinética regular
podemos especificar esto indicando que
es la energía cinética traslacional así
que ya tenemos la fórmula para la
energía cinética traslacional que es la
energía que tiene algo debido al hecho
de que el centro de masa de ese objeto
se está moviendo y también tenemos la
fórmula que toma en cuenta el hecho de
que esta masa está rotando sobre su
centro de masa y que tiene energía
cinética debido a este hecho de que está
rotando que es nuestra cara rotacional
si un objeto está rotando va a tener
energía cinética rotacional y si el
objeto se está trasladando va a tener
energía cinética traslacional es decir
que se está moviendo el centro de masa y
si el objeto se está trasladando y está
rotando pues tendremos estas dos energía
cinética ambas al mismo tiempo y esto es
lo bonito si tenemos un objeto que se
está trasladando y está rotando y
queremos encontrar la energía cinética
total de esto podemos sumar estos dos
términos si tenemos este un medio por m
por b al cuadrado
a dar la velocidad del centro de masa
así que debemos tener cuidado vamos a
hacer un poco de espacio aquí y voy a
quitar algo de esto si tomamos un medio
por m por la rapidez del centro de masa
al cuadrado obtendremos la energía
cinética traslacional total de este
objeto y si le agregamos la energía
cinética rotacional y si esto le
agregamos el un medio por iu por omega
al cuadrado es decir la omega alrededor
del centro de masa obtendremos la
energía cinética total tanto
transnacional como rotacional y esto es
genial podemos encontrar la energía
cinética del movimiento rotacional y el
movimiento traslacional simplemente
usando estas dos fórmulas del cual
podría ser un ejemplo de esto vamos a
quitar todo esto y digamos que alguien
lanza esta bola de béisbol y una pistola
de radar nos dice que esta pelota se
está moviendo a 40 metros por segundo
así que se acerca a home a 40 metros por
segundo el centro de masa de esta bola
de béisbol está moviéndose a 40 metros
por segundo pero digo
que la lanzaron como bola rápida así que
también va a estar rotando y va a estar
rotando con una velocidad angular de 50
radiales por segundo y conocemos la masa
de una bola de béisbol la busque y
resulta que es de 0.1 45 kilogramos y el
radio de esta pelota de béisbol es de
alrededor de 7 centímetros pero como lo
queremos dejar en metros pues vamos a
tener puntos 07 metros y si queremos
encontrar cuál es la energía cinética
total
vemos que tendremos una energía cinética
rotacional y una energía cinética
traslacional y la energía cinética
traslacional va a ser un medio por la
masa de la bola de béisbol por la
rapidez del centro de masa de esta bola
de béisbol al cuadrado que nos va a dar
un medio por la masa de esta pelota que
es de 0.1 45 kilogramos por la rapidez
del centro de masa de esta bola que es
de 40 metros por segundo que vamos a
elevar al cuadrado y si calculamos todo
esto nos da 116 jules denel
a cinética traslacional regular pero
cuánta energía cinética rotacional habrá
aquí tenemos energía cinética rotacional
debido al hecho de que la bola de
béisbol está girando sobre su centro de
masa cuánto va a ser bueno pues vamos a
poner un medio por iu por omega al
cuadrado bueno aquí tendremos nuestro un
medio y cuál será el momento de inercia
de esta bola de béisbol bueno es una
esfera y si buscamos el momento de
inercia de una esfera ya que no quiero
hacer la suma de todos los puntos que
componen a esta bola de béisbol si
hacemos esto usando cálculo obtendremos
esta fórmula lo que quiere decir que si
están en una clase de física que sólo
contempla el álgebra ustedes van a tener
que buscar esta fórmula ya sea en un
libro en una gráfica o en una tabla y
siempre la pueden buscar en línea y el
momento de inercia para una esfera es
dos quintos de m por r al cuadrado es
decir 200 partes de la masa de la bola
de béisbol multiplicado por el radio de
esta bola al cuadrado
y esto es y el momento de inercia el
momento de inercia de una esfera y aquí
suponemos que esta bola de béisbol es
una esfera perfecta y que tiene una
densidad uniforme lo cual no es
totalmente cierto pero es una muy buena
aproximación y esto lo multiplicamos por
omega al cuadrado la velocidad angular
al cuadrado y ahora sustituimos los
valores y nos queda un medio por dos
quintos la masa de la bola de béisbol
que es de 0.1 45 kilogramos el radio de
la bola dijimos que es de 0.07 metros
que los ponemos al cuadrado y finalmente
lo multiplicamos por omega al cuadrado
que es 50 radiales por segundo al
cuadrado y todo esto nos va a dar 0.3 55
jules así que casi nada de la energía
cinética de esta pelota viene de la
rotación casi toda la energía está en la
forma de energía cinética traslacional
lo cual tiene sentido ya que está el
hecho de que esta bola
béisbol está volando hacia home y si nos
golpea nos va a doler a diferencia de lo
que nos puede doler porque haya estado
rotando esta pelota cuando nos golpea la
rotación casi no nos va a causar ningún
daño al menos comparándola con el hecho
de que esta pelota se está moviendo a 40
metros por segundo lo cual está en la
forma de energía cinética traslacional
pero si queremos saber la energía
cinética total de esta bola de béisbol
vamos a sumar ambos términos nuestra
caja rotacional y nuestra transnacional
y esto será igual a 116 jules + 0.3 55
jules lo que nos da 116.300 55 jules en
resumen si un objeto está rotando y se
está trasladando podemos encontrar la
energía cinética traslacional con esta
fórmula un medio por m por la rapidez
del centro de masa al cuadrado y podemos
encontrar la energía cinética rotacional
usando un medio de y mayúscula el
momento de inercia
para cualquiera que sea la forma que
tenga este objeto si fuera una masa
puntual moviéndose en un gran círculo
sería m por r al cuadrado si el objeto
fuera una esfera que está rotando en su
centro de masa podemos usar dos quintos
de m por r al cuadrado los cilindros son
un medio por m por r al cuadrado y
ustedes pueden buscar la fórmula
correspondiente a la forma del objeto
que quieren encontrar su energía
cinética rotacional multiplicado por la
rapidez angular al cuadrado que se mueve
alrededor de ese centro de masa y si
sumamos ambos términos obtendremos la
energía cinética total de ese objeto